- [Instructor] I'm here at
the Khan Academy exercise
called Find One on the Number Line
and they're asking us to do exactly that.
It says, "Move the dot to
one on the number line,"
and it's a little interactive dot
that I can move around.
And so, let's think
about how I would do it
and I always encourage you,
pause this video and see at least how
you would think about doing it
or put your finger on the
screen where you think one is
and then we'll work through it together.
All right.
So they've told us where zero is
and they've told us
where seven fourths is.
So one thing I could do is
I could say well how many
of these equal spaces
does it take me to get
from zero to seven fourths.
So let's see it's one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
So if it takes seven equal
spaces to get to seven fourths,
that means that each of
these spaces is one fourth
because then it would be
one fourth, two fourths,
three fourths, four fourths,
five fourths, six fourths,
and seven fourths.
All right, we're making
some good progress.
So where would one be?
Well, one would be four fourths.
So we would go one fourth,
two fourths, three fourths,
and then four fourths.
So that's where one is.
So the important thing to
realize is the only way
we knew that each of
these, each of these gaps,
or each of these spaces
from one hash to the next,
the way that we knew that
each of those is a fourth
is by saying hey look,
seven of those equal spaces
get us to seven fourths,
so each of these must be a fourth.
So four of those, four
fourths, would be equal to one.
Let's do another example.
So here, we're said,
we're told to move the dot
to one on the number line.
So put your finger on where
that would be on the screen.
Pause the video and do that.
All right.
In some ways this is a little bit easier
because they told us that going from zero
to the next little cross or
hash, I guess you could say,
whatever you want to call
these things, is one sixth.
So what is one?
Well, one or one whole is six sixths.
So this is one sixth,
two sixths, three sixths,
four sixths, five sixths,
and then six sixths.
So there we go.
That is where is one
is on this number line.